a reality is just what we tell each
other it is sane and insane could easily
switch places at the insane would have
become a majority you would find
yourself locked in a padded cell
wondering what happened to them oh
alright it's Friday we're doing another
movie review doing another John
Carpenter movie and another Lovecraftian
movie yeah that happens yeah part of our
little Lovecraft series yeah we just
kind of ended up watching a lot of sort
of Lovecraftian horror on to be so
that's how we ended up doing this and we
owe and we love John Carpenter so we end
up doing a lot of John Carpenter but we
somebody actually suggested that we do
like director retrospectives you know
like we could do a Joe carpenter one we
although I don't know that might be kind
of redundant because we because we've
done so many if is where we kind of
least in this case it we kind of recap
you know the door what's happening with
directors usually whenever we talk about
an individual film that they're doing
that's yes I mean that might be kind of
its kind of written I think it's kind of
redundant and that way where a person is
just looking for a review of this film
can find additional information
although Carpenter doesn't really need
an introduction i don't think no i'm
busily it's not the word community for
him and takes and right you know it's
this is a kind of another movie and i
mentioned this when we reviewed i
mentioned this when we reviewed body
bags which came out in 1993 that you
know i had always been kind of under the
perception that well you know they live
for my sanity a it was the last movie of
his that i really liked but then I was
like no body bags I forgot about that
when that came out in 1993 and for some
reason I always forget about this one
too I don't forget about the movie per
se it's just that sometimes for whatever
reason I forget that John Carpenter
directed it and it is in the mouth of
madness which came out in 1995 first I'm
not really entirely sure why I have this
weird kind of disconnect like why I
always forget that this is a John
Carpenter movie maybe it's because I
don't want to say it's unlike any of his
other movies it's it's sort of a
different theme but not it's kinda like
hard uh kind of hard to explain even
though I don't think he wrote it no you
didn't okay a little bit this is
actually considered unofficially the
third film in his quote unquote
apocalypse trilogy first of those being
the thing
and second of those being Prince of
Darkness which man you know I've said
about that Oh what we should do a show
on it just because yeah I want to get I
want to get it as part of this yeah
metal books or a steelbook series yeah
so we'll do a show on it's one that I
want to like but it she seems like every
time i rewatch it like I'd give it
another chance and it just it seems like
a cool idea but in a way it seems like
too many ideas herbs like to Klum's day
was making enough disease going it kind
of felt like that now this one is kind
of different though and in the mouth of
madness seems to be one of those movies
in the horror community that is either
love it or hate it now I have seen some
people online that have made the very
bold statement that in the mouth of
madness is their favorite carpenter
movies I have to go back to see it again
which like I said that's I mean when I
was in your hole when your filmography
includes the thing and Holly and an
escape from New York I mean I wouldn't
go that far
yeah I don't see how this can beat the
thing the thing is a masterpiece but I
can see how it can be one of your
favorite one us carpenter ones because I
definitely think it's one of his better
movies and easily probably his best
movie the 90s just think there's a lot
of competition in that area I mean the
movie has chest and then it doesn't it
doesn't have cross although it's not a
Carver to flick it's not an iconic
carpenter flick if you ask me well what
does not fulfill Russell wasn't it
Halloween does not fulfill my cross old
man crush it just tell I'm very sorry
about okay on the lettuce slide okay
that's a good flavor yeah this movie
like I said it's very Lovecraftian
actually John Carpenter did not direct
it or did not write it rather it was
written by Michael De Luca who at the
time was the head of New Line Cinema our
head of production he actually went on
to direct some pretty well-regarded
films he did I think he did v for any
movie I want to say but he actually got
some Oscars he did blade he did bogey
night
seated awesome powers Magnolia American
history acts stuff like that so you know
he's the one that wrote this story he
actually wrote it in the late 80s about
88 or 89 he first offered it to
carpenter but carpenter said no so then
he offered it to another director named
Tony Randall who had done Hellraiser 2
and that guy kind of worked on it for a
little while and said [ __ ] that and I
want to do it and then it was offered to
Mary Lambert
who's probably most famous for in the
horror community for directing Pet
Sematary and she was kind of attached to
it for a little while but then it didn't
work out then finally in the 90s about
92 carpenter said okay I'll do it now
the story is very it's one of those ones
it seems like the 90s particularly the
horror genre was very into meta fictions
you know I mean like Wes Craven had done
the new nightmare I think it was you
know there were there was like this
thing where the Freddy and all the
characters from The Nightmare on Elm
Street movies were so popular that it
was starting to bleed into reality and
affecting the lives of the actors so it
was kind of like a meta thing that way
too
you know you had stuff like scream and
things like that there were kind of
self-referential so this was kind of
along the same line where they were kind
of blurring the line between what was
fiction and what was reality yeah but
this one had a much larger scope I mean
this was like a world ending apocalyptic
kind of story which happened Earl Ike's
those yeah and at the end it got real
meta like you watching this movie are
now gonna be affected by this that this
is the movie version of the book that
this guy is writing and you're in this
somehow yeah it's pretty weird yes it's
kind of one of those things where if you
see it you understand oh no that doesn't
make any sense well it's one of those
movies where if you like horror movies
that are you know very straightforward
and very explained and you know
everything has a reason and stuff like
that then probably you're not gonna roll
with this because one criticism I seal
is oh it doesn't make any sense what
makes sense
it's like what's real and what's not
yeah and all this other kind of [ __ ]
sense but and I'm watching it and I'm
know I know that I'm missing certain
details yeah it's something that you you
have to view a couple of times to get a
full grip on what's happening yeah
there's a really lot you lost oh and
there's a lot of like references to
other yeah they're trying to meta you
out in certain ways like what when you
see it you'll know yeah and I mean the
whole thing what kind of like going to
the plot a little bit Sam Neill is the
is John Tran sense the main character
and I actually love that they got Sam
Neill to be this character because this
story gets so crazy I mean the whole
thing is just about insanity and about
the lines between reality and fiction
blurring so they had to get somebody
that was a believable skeptical guy that
is just not going along with any of this
[ __ ]
right you know until he doesn't really
have a choice and I think he really
sells it yeah and the interesting thing
about this and this was something that I
think John Carpenter said maybe on the
commentary of this movie that Sam Neill
decided he was going to play this
character as though he was in a comedy
okay and it actually works pretty well I
think he's almost it's almost like a
throwback to a film noir type of
character he's like a private dick he's
an insurance investigator and he's very
world weary and he's very like what is
this [ __ ] everything's a scam everything
sucks it's like he's just kind of like
that and I think that works really well
because it really offsets all this crazy
Lovecraftian [ __ ] that's going on in
other parts yeah you know in a weird way
that the movies about Stephen King
ending the world in a certain way yeah
that's a very good thing that Stephen
King is actually writing books that are
that are bringing about the apocalypse
in the return of the old ones from
Lovecraftian yeah they're coming from
these others you mentioned yes yeah
because the the writer that this tyke is
you know John Trent the main character
he's played by Sam Neill he is hired by
arcane publishing which is headed by the
Cheston yeah Cheston to go and find this
super ridiculously popular best-selling
horror author named Sutter cane who has
disappeared before he was supposed to
turn in the final manuscript of his new
book which they've already pre-sold
they've already sold the movie rights
all this other kind of stuff but now
they don't know where he went and of
course Sutter cane it means Stephen King
yes okay well if you look at all the the
book covers of his that they're showing
think they use the same font font and
the same like font design like the way
they have the best in the K but the s
and the G big and stuff yeah and the
titles of all of the southern center
Cannes books are like Lovecraft titles
story titles but just like one word off
right you know what I mean so it's he's
almost like an amalgam of Stephen King
and HP so you know John Carpenter here
or Michael DeLuca I guess it's he's the
one to write the story he's kind of
making a commentary on writers whose
work becomes so big that stress effect
and it starts bleeding into reality yeah
because the whole thing about Sutter
cane is that apparently he's this writer
of these Lovecraftian fictions and the
more people believe that his stuff is
real the more its able to manifest
itself in reality yeah and that's that
he's probably also kind of making a call
back to Lovecraft himself because in
Lovecraft day when he was writing all
this these mythos news books they had
people that actually believed this was
real and that Lovecraft was somehow
channeling all this they wanted to know
where the Necronomicon was and there was
no Necronomicon this is this look that
made that up yeah but there was a like a
little cult forming around Lovecraft so
in a way you can kind of see where this
idea comes from that's kind of I think
where Michael DeLuca got the idea for we
so like you know if enough people
believe in it does it become reality but
then there's another layer to the movie
too because in the opening scenes we see
cuz the interpreter which the entire
movie is a flashback yeah and it's told
from John Trent's point of view and at
the beginning of the movie John Trent is
being put into an insane asylum yeah
mental hospital he draws crosses all
over himself and all over the walls
yeah and stuff like that and he is
relating what drove him crazy to dr. wen
who is played by David Warner who I love
so that introduces another layer of
uncertainty because you're told from the
jump that John Trent is an unreliable
narrator is he crazy and all of this
none of this stuff ever happened has the
world gone crazy and the world is ending
and he's the only sane person so they
slap him in an asylum
just like which is what one of the
characters says to him you know the
midpoint in the movie or you know so it
could kind of be read either way that's
kind of what makes it cool and another
thing that I want to say about this
movie like I said some of the stuff you
know once it seems pretty
straightforward you know he gets John
Trent gets hired by Charlton Heston her
chest and rather to go and find I got
people trained to cry - yes in case
you're a new listener Crossley's Kurt
Russell yeah I just yeah you've just in
his charlton heston
so it's kind of straightforward then he
gets hired to go find this writer
because he's disappeared he's like I
need that manuscript because we pre-sold
all this stuff the woman that goes with
him Linda Stiles is Sarah Cain's editor
so these two try to go find him now in
really beginning John Trent has gotten
threatened with an ax by Center canes
former agent who was gonna kill him in a
coffee shop it was funny because John
Trent's like surprisingly cool about
this I think the agent comes electricy
get him through the window with the axe
and he's just like huh all right well
that's how that [ __ ] goes you know like
I said and it works very well because
he's just so nonchalant about every
breath so he starts having like these
kind of weird nightmares and stuff and
visions and
and then he figures out like he figures
well baby if I read some of his books
then I'll figure out where he went to
now there has been some hint earlier on
in the movie that reading his books can
drive some people crazy right and so
which explains the the agent flipping
out with the axe so as he starts reading
the books he starts seeing fangs and
stuff but then like he has all the books
on his coffee table and he notices that
all the cover art makes like a little
map of New Hampshire and there's this
one little spot on it he's like oh well
maybe that sneaky [ __ ] maybe
that's where he's at and it turns out to
be a town called Hobbs end which is
purportedly a fictional town it's kind
of like the Castle Rock of Stephen King
it's like one that he growed up yeah so
him and the editor they're like cool
baby that's where he is he's at this
spot on the map yeah but there's no
there's nothing there's no Hobbs in
there right yes so you know he's like
yeah but the weird thing is that when
they start driving to it then it's
almost kind of like they go through this
weird in time corner like everything
goes black and like they start seeing
like she sees this weird kid on a
bicycle and stuff like all this like
really weird juggling and they actually
get there and then they actually get
there so there is a town that supposedly
doesn't exist yeah so they're in a town
that it dude made up and wrote and be
like going to Castle Rock yeah it's like
that right and all this really weird
shady [ __ ] happens there like I said
there's a lot of Lovecraftian kinda
there's like all the kids look really
weird and deformed there's this really
big creepy black church yeah there's
some people I think thought was a matte
painting but that is an actual place
it's in Ontario it's called the
Cathedral of the Transfiguration okay
yeah so they filmed that there it's like
you know there's just all these little
weird details like they go in this hotel
which is right which I love it's run by
this old lady named mrs. Pikmin like a
Lovecraft Story pickman's model and she
seems all nice and everything and then
there's but there's all this sinister
[ __ ] going on there's like a painting in
there that changes every time you look
at it it's like I like all those kind of
little details like that makes me want
to
again now you're talking about like
three-legged and like yeah and so I like
I said I kind of like all these really
subtle
yeah and I'm settling images they
actually meet Sutter cane he's in there
yeah he's writing books and he's trying
to finish this book and when it's
finished it's gonna bring the old ones
out of their realm into our realm and
they show yeah they're pretty good gonna
show so this is all no CG this is all
practical effects yeah monsters that the
monsters won I think the only CGI was
kind of like the book stuff like when
senator came like tears himself up and
things like that maybe I think it'll
maybe yeah but most most of the creature
effects and all that kind of stuff and
they'll write and they're really one
creepy unsettling scene where the editor
gets out of the car and her head is all
yeah that was actually done with parts
fluids and then there's a scene where
they open up a door and the old ones
start coming from their dimension they
show they look kind of like something
out of the thing yeah really cool though
but like I said the cool thing about
this is that you never really know I
mean because this the whole movie is
like the end of it is almost like an
infinite loop yeah he's not sure if
you're being told a story or if this is
something that's it really happening yes
and it's almost kind of like like you
don't know if he was just telling you a
crazy story this whole that did all of
this stuff happen it's kind of like it
almost implicates the viewer right and
so I actually think it's one of the best
metaphor yes cuz it's it's like all this
is happening this story is happening in
a book that if you read this book it
actually makes it happen yeah and the
movie that you're watching is the movie
of that book everything is like super
self referential and there's a and if
you're really into if you're really into
horror particularly Lovecraftian horror
there's a lot of like really and I like
what the character names and stuff like
that that kind of refer back to it and I
think a lot of the imagery is really
cool too I mean it's carpenter so he's
kind of got that all of that Carpinteria
thing
with his lighting and all that kind of
stuff oh what fun fact you know the part
where John Trent he's he kind of thinks
he wakes up out of it he's like at that
crossroads and there's nobody else
around and then left and then that
paperboy rides on the bicycle you know
who that kid is ooh
Hayden Christensen who's that yes you're
right Anakin Skywalker yeah that's funny
but like I just saw that as some little
trivial thing on that all the web and I
was like that okay and it turns out it's
on the Wikipedia page too right there
this is kind of like it seems like one
of his kind of underrated kind of movies
yeah I want to see it again now that
we're talking about yeah like if you
liked like I said I didn't I didn't see
it when it came out I didn't yeah I
think I saw it maybe in the late 90s
yeah once it came out that's that one I
don't think I set aside it earlier yeah
you really pay closer dude it's funny
because when I first saw it I don't
remember seeing in the theater I very
well may have I did see a lot of movies
but it had a tone and a look of many
other horror movies from that time yes
you know kind of merged in with some of
the other stuff that was happening but
you look at it now it was different cuz
like I said there was a lot of
metafiction kind of on you know you had
a new nightmare II if I think even Clive
Barker's Lord of illusions that might
have been out around that same time
which is I think if I recall it was a
similar kind of premise kind like
Jacob's Ladder or yeah Jacob's Ladder
that kind of thing where everything was
you weren't sure it was real what was it
which I usually love I love like a mug
you as horror so that's kind of why I
really like this one it's interesting
because maybe this kind of ties back to
what you said I think horror
particularly and maybe all movies but
you know sometimes kind of a nerd
probably this is why I'm thinking this
but I feel like horror is more
appreciated later yeah you can't ask to
age you can't really appreciate your
album
yeah sure album comes out you don't
really like it and then like five years
later you're like that was an awesome
album yeah it needs some time just do
not always like some time
some horror movies I think are better
appreciated in the cultural time you
know that they came out but in general I
think most horror ages better and the
thing is once it ages out some like you
said this movie might not have stood out
as much when it first came out at 95 and
I think blend it in but since all the
crappy ones have since fallen away and
no one really remembers them anymore
this one kind of sticks out yeah I think
it's kind of the same thing with music
where sometimes like I said where you
don't really appreciate it till later
because you know all the other crappy
[ __ ] from around the same time this is
dis
it's been forgotten and just the good
stuff did you rank this in in carpenter
filmography oh gosh um better than
Prince of Darkness yeah I really really
don't like príncipe as much as I want to
like Prince of Darkness I just can't I
can't muster it up there's parts of it I
love there's parts of it that are
brilliant it's not as good as the thing
[Music]
I'd say it was maybe almost like body
bags very different story but at this
yeah because it's one story because
that's one story I gosh but I'm gonna
say we were talking about this when we
were walking the other day in general
other than this movie in general I think
carpenter is a better director when the
stories are simpler straightforward
which maybe that might be why I
sometimes forget mrs. carpenter because
this story is very kind of complex and
multi-layered and stuff I feel like what
he does movies like that I don't like
them as much I think that's kind of the
problem that I had with Prince of
Darkness it seemed like there were too
many ideas stuffed in it and they
weren't all that well delineated and
they didn't really go together that well
I really didn't get the mechanism by
which this was happening and it's a
better quality production than they live
yeah it looks better than not what is
driving as they live because that's very
simple yeah it's a very straight put it
on par with they live in terms of yeah I
get you know I can't really I can't
really group this in yeah the Prince of
Darkness and thing I just can't
I'd have to group this in more with
Dagon yeah even though I kind of out of
the two I kind of like the feel of Dagon
better but I would watch this along with
dig on and reanimate ER and brighter
reanimate er and from beyond you know
it's it's rough it always strikes me is
more Lovecraftian movie than a carpet
yeah good things but if I had to rank it
like in the carpet I actually think I
like it a little bit better than they
live so it's technical it's bigger scope
it's a bigger scope I tend to like like
I said I take the likes better ambiguity
I tend to like those types
I like Lovecraftian fiction anything
that has this kind of surrealist you
know what and you know what it's cutting
this is almost kind of like a high
quality the fog yeah Lovecraft first
yeah that's a good way of putting it
it's not quite as subtle as the fog rugs
I mean the fog was pretty much just a
straight story but this has that kind of
restrained I don't want to say
restrained that's not really the right
word but insidious kind of yeah that's a
good that's a good word um yeah again it
has like just these really nice surreal
little touches like the kid on the
bicycle like I'm gonna say it I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say it's an upscale the
fog and the Lovecraft yeah that's
probably but yeah it does seem like it's
a little bit underappreciated I feel
like it's gotten more love in the last
few years because you know the reviews
I've read of it recently that have been
done recently a lot of people are saying
you know this is a really you know it's
really good and it's kind of forgotten
really definitely one of the better
carpenter movies easily the best
carpenter movie the 90s yeah you know
there's not a lot of common competition
in that area aged well yeah I want to
see it again now I have it on the
blu-ray and you know it's a regular
blu-ray releases I think the screen
factory that really released that it was
yeah yeah and the transfer looked
fantastic it did look really nice before
thee good so you can get that on eBay
for probably around 10 bucks 10 15 bucks
yeah it's a good buy and I ended up
liking it a lot more lucky said well I
think if I saw it in the theater which I
may have or I saw it back in the mid to
late 90s it didn't make a huge
impression but when I saw
yeah you're like oh yes kind of forgot
about it yeah like you said I think
maybe the shitty movies from yes and
faded the shitty movie from the 90s kind
of drowned this one out they blended in
with them in a certain way now but I
think it was mostly the tone and the
look of the nineties kind of obscured
this one it's good though in a way it
kind of felt like what was that 1 7 yes
the you knew it called 7 in a Jacob's
Ladder and in a way almost like that
terrible Arnold Schwarzenegger film that
kind of had that scene look at the field
what was that tow the apocalyptic one
yeah end of days garbage and I love
Swardson that grad you like and I well I
love Gabriel Byrne I saw that [ __ ] in
the theater and the only reason I went
to see it was I was like oh it's about
Devils and Gabriel Byrne is in it yeah
but I yeah I really did not like it it
was like the time I met mash to genres
together yes let's make the omen took
like an action but like an action movie
like yeah but it wasn't garbage but
there was something about this I don't
do it something good believe me well I
have to say I have experienced suckage
for myself
you know I mean and I like Arnie I just
wanted to see how [ __ ] up it was yeah
and yeah and the days just [ __ ] up
yeah it's so terrible yeah but I like
that okay I like the one about the clone
so it was the sixth day that was good I
liked that one I might have that one
eventually you'll like it yeah it's good
it's almost kind of like it reminded me
of Total Recall even though I loved the
meta action of Total Recall yes and
we've been you know for you people know
it look he was back at recall he was
tripping did not go to Mars he did not
get his ass to Mars well the thing about
it is and it's funny that you bring up
shuttle recall because this one yeah
that's what does that matter
I think going over you're not really
sure what's going on a little bit
Twilight Zone yeah it's a little bit has
an aspect of a Twilight Zone kind of
episode but a really really good one in
a really big high budget one it reminds
me of that also right but like I said
you know it's good because I think it
really needs a revisit because I think
if you saw it at the time it might not
have been like yeah I saw it at the time
and I was like yeah me was so good that
I think some of his 90s stuff kind of
pales by comparison so you know not
saying although it was the car under
Cronenberg kind of thing that was going
on at that time
yeah pressed our generation this is a
90s version of that this could have
easily been done by Cronenberg it does
seem yeah it seemed kind of Cronenberg
in all right we're just not making that
association because it looks and feels
so 90s
but this which is funny before I and if
you kids are younger I mean you know
we're in our 40s yeah when it was the
90s yeah I didn't really notice a look
of the night yeah and today I'm so later
and then you're looking back on oh my
god yeah well even though when you're in
it doesn't really yeah it doesn't it's
not like it's not like the sets look 90s
or the people look so nice although it
doesn't certain certain respects there
was a certain tone to horror movies
other 90s yeah in the same way there was
a certain tone to horror movies of the
80s yeah and the 90s tone I got really
burned out on it quick I know so many of
them most and most of a bore [ __ ] well
and they I think the thing about 90s
horror movies in general a lot of them
and even a lot of them now when I we see
them again a lot of them came off as
very generic I don't know that was the
cinematography know if it was just the
the way the actors looked I don't know
it was a script writing I don't I don't
I can't put my finger on and there was
so they all looked similar looks like a
generic 90s satanic slash goth kind of
thing and it was a mainstream
interpretation of God thinking it was
just maybe yeah it was like yeah as if
Walt Disney was giving you gothic you
know
was almost kind of like yeah Hollywood
just discovered Gotham yes like now we
have to put that in every yeah and there
burn lights Here I am since then yes
1983 you guys are just like making this
really slick interpretation yeah not to
[ __ ] on some of the movies good strong
more good I like the craft for example
yeah and things like that I don't listen
the first two blades were like those you
know so I don't want to [ __ ] on a too
much but this one didn't really have
that problem so much but it still kind
of had that look and like I said there
were other movies out there were kind of
like this yeah the first crow yeah right
um you know like Lord of illusions and
stuff so yeah so it was a similar kind
of thing going on
and for all those kind of generic
nineties movies I blame screen I like
scream that's a great movie it's a
classic but the [ __ ] that came in its
wake right where everything were now all
the 90s were after that had to be ironic
and self-referential and jokey and [ __ ]
like that that really kind of pissed me
off so I'm kind of glad that that era
passed and now people are actually
taking her seriously again and actually
making really good creepy allegorical
yeah some of this some these independent
horror movies that we're seeing on
Netflix are excellent there's a really
really good ones I'm very good I mean
I've been very pleasantly surprised
because I always said when I was growing
up I said I don't want to be one of
those crabby old people's like are they
scared today you know and stuff like
that so I do try to I made one to have
time to I do try to keep up with new
indie horror and stuff like that and a
lot of the new stuff I've seen were said
been fantastic yeah well they're getting
away from the Hollywood scene and
they're doing it locally with their own
people and their own money and their own
equipment doing what they want to do and
they're able to get it released it's
awesome and a lot of them are are even
if they're younger than us they seem to
be fans of the old same horror movies
that we grew up while well the movies
that actually started some of these
labels like phantasm you know they were
little programs you know they were
Friday the 13th it was a little homemade
films you know yeah and you know in the
way that's how Carpenter got his start
well and I was going to say the guy that
in the mouth of madness I mean he was
head of New Line Cinema New Line Cinema
I think was served by Roger Corman
they called that studio in the 80s they
called it the house that Freddy belts
because Nightmare on Elm Street was an
independent film they made it their [ __ ]
tons of money and then it went on to
become a much bigger company because of
that franchise right yeah so a lot of
the horror from that era started out as
independents and later on it got picked
up right by big studios increased the
creativity creativity always comes from
you know independent stuff yeah I mean
Hollywood picks up runs it into the
ground just like custom motorcycles cool
[ __ ] never comes from manufacturers it
comes out of some dudes garage movies
are like that yeah I mean the thing is
our wars all independent movies are
because a lot of them suck yeah I mean a
lot of really crappy
it's just it's just like you're not sure
it's a swamp it's a quagmire of natural
selection the good stuff will eventually
kind of rise to the top yeah nuts that's
what you're seeing Ian I mean we know
[ __ ] we've like mentioned some newer
movies on some ships so bad that it
rises to the top look at Manos hands of
fate that [ __ ] is so bad that it's good
there's something like intriguing about
yeah something really creepy about that
movie yes like it was a movie made by
and I think that Joel and the box kind
of nailed it when they did it on the
original in the second season five or
whatever when he said every frame of
this movie looks like someone's last
known just like we're filming a crime
and they're being forced to do this I
can only film 30 seconds at a time just
and I can't everybody looks like they're
forced to be forced to be in this movie
they should like it they're at gunpoint
yeah you're making a sequel like the
girl that played Debbie in that movie
she has a Facebook group and I'm on it
because that was her dad that played a
master
it's like Birdemic remember began
but I show that I can't figure out if
they were legitimately trying to make a
good movie or if they were just said
[ __ ] this is buckets so it was a good
had to be it had to been some kind of a
corporate effort like I'll make your
movie for your corporation I'll plug you
just give me the money I'll make it what
was with the guys I'm a hack did it and
it was just so hackish that it rose out
of the clinic brilliant yeah it was like
I said it was natural selection it Rose
itself yeah I mean that guy found that
he was making like a masterpiece of
romantic comedy or drama I can't figure
out what it was most amazing
but it was so bad yeah that it became
awesome yeah I always feel like you
can't do that on purpose
because I you know likes like the sci-fi
channel it makes like sharknado here if
you're making like a parody on purpose
like you're trying to make it bad on
purpose yeah it's not gonna work though
you have to think you're making the best
movie ever it has unique manically you
need that earnest yes
that's what makes it funny yeah it
actually has to be somebody who really
thinks it special effects are good right
then and then if it sucks then it's
beautiful okay all right yeah we were
talking about John Carpenter or you're
pretty much like I said I don't want to
ruin it too much but the thing about it
is the plot is not really the most
important thing about this it's really
more about the atmosphere the the
statement that it makes you know love
the imagery it has really really cool
like creepy surrealistic kind of if you
like to other carbon reflections like
this way and if you like Lovecraftian
yeah kind of true stuff
imagine Lovecraft meets the fog kind of
like that oh you know speaking of
Lovecraft someone had on YouTube has
recommended we saw Call of Cthulhu the
black-and-white one right that was
I like okay that same studio has made
another one okay they made I think it
was whisper in the darkness
okay so we're definitely gonna have to
look better on see it because I would
really really like sigh don't we oughta
do a show on both of them
oh that's a good idea a lot of crafts
we'll just put that in those two of the
series yeah all right all right so
that'll do it for this installment of
our movie retrospective series remember
to check out our regular show that comes
out every Tuesday and our movie reviews
that come out every Friday and if you'd
like to financially support the show you
can go to our patreon page or go to our
vlog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress calm and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you would
like to make a one-time donation we will
see you next time bye